so it is the 25th anniversary of the fox
news channel it's today you've probably
seen the great promos the channel's been
running all week about that but today is
the day we've got one of our favorite
people at fox to join us in a minute to
assess the last quarter century but
first we want to take you back to that
day this was 25 years ago today as it
started watch
we've now reached this moment when we
can firmly announce
the starting of a fox news channel and a
much
greater effort on the build up of fox
news
in every area we now see
a fairly defined audience in numbers
for cnn
i think you'll find as more news
channels and particularly our news
channel up here the audience
will increase greatly
so that was before it even started
actually that was in
1996
95
nobody thought that was going to work in
the news business at the time i worked
at another competing channel which was
then number one and happened to be in
the room on the very first day that this
channel went on the air i was covering
bob dole was running for president he
was one of the very first guests in a
room full of reporters covering the dole
campaign there was not a single person
including me who thought this would work
another news channel really
but it did work and it worked for a
couple of important reasons first you
had really smart
and really committed people running them
one of those people was roger ailes who
was the creative force behind a lot of
what you saw on the air
here he is
we're not starting up a reactive news
service here in any way
our job is to be objective we'd like to
be premier journalists we'd like to
restore objectivity
where we find it lacking so we just
expect to do fine balanced journalism
that's been said about roger ailes not
sure how much we can add to that other
than to point out
that man understood people human nature
tv talent better than really anybody
and that turned out to be massively
important but over the years the single
most important quality the quality that
has allowed this channel to continue and
thrive for a quarter century is courage
the belief that we are doing something
important by letting people talk
lachlan murdoch has taken over
suzanne scott jay wallace running it day
to day the one thing they have in common
in addition to being really nice people
is that they are totally committed to
the freedom of speech do they agree with
everything we say on this show or other
shows we have no idea they've never told
us what we do know is that they have a
bedrock
unshakable belief that the first
amendment is real and that we are the
living embodiment of it you can tell the
truth on fox news
period it's not easy to do that takes
enormous toughness we're grateful to
them every day for that hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else